succedendo indennità perdendo il senno
vorrei far vedere che cosa hanno fatto
hanno scardinato la porta per poter
riprendere da fuori ci stanno divorando
le zanzare possiamo iniziare a cucinare
ciao ragazzi bentornati in una puntata
di cucina buttata ora questa con una
puntata speciale perché per chi vi
voglio parlare di una cosa che ho fatto
quest'estate grazie a conad e insieme a
chiara maci e marchal ascani siamo
andati in giro per l'italia in quello
che è stato veramente un tour i figli
direbbero enogastronomico io direi un
turno il quale mi sono mangiato
veramente qualsiasi cosa hanno
spazzolato il territorio con la lingua
alla scoperta della filiera ora io non
sapevo che cosa che forse la filiera ma
fondamentalmente questa catena che
unisce produttore distributore e cliente
ora questi qui sono dei grandissimi
paroloni ma di base con abbiamo fatto è
stato ma riceve dal momento che conad
copre tutto quanto il territorio
italiano ho pensato di fare un piccolo
esperimento ossia ho pensato di mettere
tutta quanta l'italia in un piatto e
qual è la cosa che forse ci rappresenta
più di tutte se non la pasta col
pomodoro partiamo subito con la ricetta
per fare la pasta al pomodoro classica
avremo bisogno di pomodoro del sud è
sceso molto il sud pomodoro dicono
mangiare pomodoro piccadilly che mi
dicono si usi più al nord però non ne
sono sicuro ditemi voi
la prima perché ci sta la passata
aquilani per barare
no questa non lo useremo di sicuro a
basta ora il discorso è se quanto
abbiamo preso o degli spaghetti oppure
dei rigatoni integrali qua dipende da
cosa vogliamo fare se qualcosa di più
tradizionale oppure un qualcosa di
pochino più dietetico no sia prodotto
prima ma quanto resistente alla pasta
trafilata al bronzo
aglio parmigiano reggiano ragazzi vi
giuro sul mio onore o grattugiato io vi
giuro che non l'ho fatto già grattugiato
e che bisogna sempre come dice chiara
maci olio sale e zucchero e infine
quello che secondo me c'è un ape e
infine quello che secondo me è il vero
protagonista di questo piatto ossia il
basilico altrimenti chiamato ernesto
allora questa è una cosa che ancora una
volta mi ha insegnato chiara maci cioè
le erbette queste cose così se si può
le all'est learn est e si vede prendete
le fresche 3 avanti partiamo subito col
piatto alla per prima cosa prende un
pochino di pachino e di piccadilly vi do
una bella sciacquata una volta
sciacquati andiamo a tagliarli che è il
pomodoro è molto facile e prendi il
pomodoro
prendi un coltello sì è vero ci stanno
persone che non amano la pelle io per
esempio lo preferisco con la pelle
questa è una domanda interessante
a voi piace sbocciato non sbocciato no
davvero scherzi a parte bus sbucciato la
pelle vi da fastidio oppure no è
imbarazzante questa domanda se non è più
buono con con capitola
il più serio è davanti ma che davvero li
metti nel pime
ma se un genio di cipolla e di olio
insieme a pomodori pronto e faccio
essere qui a raccontarlo ragazzi domanda
è come lo fate voi
per esempio nei pomodorini che
appassiscono che muoiono l'istat
mi piace io amo di meno il sugo
perfettamente liscio come le penne lisce
tutto ciò che il vicino lisci non lo
credo qualcuno possa veramente mangiare
ferisce sono fatte così può andare
canali finiscono ma kate ha infatti
eliminato
sì perché questa violenza verbale
mettiamo un attimo da parte i pomodori a
questo punto è la grande mossa che sto
per insegnare la seguente quando bisogna
far bollire l'acqua mettete la già calda
per due motivi uno perché vuole più
velocemente è il secondo è perché si
attiva la caldaia che filtra
maggiormente l'acqua passa pure per
tutti quanti filtri anti fango anti roba
un problema enorme
non ho una padella se non ce l'hai in
una padella che devo cambiarla qualcuno
mi regalo da parte dopo che io nel
frattempo faccio andare a questo punto
che stiamo soffritto senza padella con
le mani a userò questo
a questo punto piccolo trucco personale
che una mia preferenza in questa qui è
una cosa che ho visto fare in una delle
tappe molise vecchia visto già la
puntata lo sa ma ci stanno questi chef
che ci hanno provato questa super pasta
col sugo e loro schiacciavano e lo
buttavano vestito non lo so non visto e
lo faccio anch'io d'ora in poi lo metto
vestito aziz in camicia vestito cioè in
un nudo
mettete un anno pudico nell'olio e
questa è una cosa mia che faccia ragazzi
io prendo un po di foglie di basilico e
mi butto a soffriggere in modo da creare
un olio aromatizzato aglio e basilico
pensare sempre le foglietti è un'altra
cosa fare spezzarne questo modo
spezzandole sarà più facile tirare fuori
il suq è un'altra cosa che faccio questo
qui è una cosa che insegna tutti quanti
voi ma che in realtà mi è stato
insegnato da un altro ragazzo con lo
chef
quando fate il soffritto inclinate
sempre la padella sì perché in questo
modo quello che succede ah no è spento
poco
perché in questo modo avrete tutte
quante le cose che buttate all'interno
dell'olio coperte per intero e quindi
lascia migliore si degli aromi e poi c'è
chi non ama l'aglio per esempio nel
soffritto ci metterà cipolla pure ci
mettono il peperoncino l'alice è vero
sono varie scuole di pensiero la mia e
mette il basilico soffriggere
criticatemi comunque l'ho scoperto
perché servono le padelle rischiando di
uccidermi per fare questa cosa al volo
togliamo sia l'aglio che le foglie di
basilico e stiamo dentro i pomodorini
buttiamo sale diciamo così zucchero e
basi volo mettere sempre presente io sto
facendo un test a caracalla caracalla
caracalla
se guardate guardate guardate guardate
l'odore è tipo odore d'italia ok e copri
al mondo e adesso fondamentalmente
aspettiamo ha fatto ci vuole un quarto
dove non lo so guarda ogni tanto gli
date nel romena da una bella rumena del
come si dice in sicilia 56 con gli altri
ci vorrà pochissimo perché il sugo
inizierà subito a raddrizzarsi anche
abbastanza velocemente assecondare la
fiamma che mettete sotto potrete fare il
sugo in poco o in tanto tempo è ovvio
che quello che parlano nei quattro ore è
più buono non mi chiedete perché non lo
è invece quello più veloci è
semplicemente più comodo che tutto ciò
intanto che aspetto questo così faccio
volevo spendere una parola per il paese
nel quale viviamo cioè noi viviamo in un
posto che ha una cultura del cibo unica
mangi d'addio ai una varietà assurda e
questa è una cosa che è talmente
pochissimi altri paesi possono vantare
non mi vengono in mente altri posti ed è
per questo
non avrei diventi quasi pronto apriamo
gli spaghetti se qui dice 8 minuti
io metto il timer a cinque minuti perché
finire una cottura all'interno del suo
ragazzi quanti siamo quindi hanno
stanato una pasta di stato dimenticato
lista dare l'acqua della pasta comunque
ci saranno alcuni che bolla saranno sin
da subito si andò a bollore perché fa
risparmiare teoricamente lo caccia
allora io non ho ancora capito quale sia
la fisica che si nasconde dietro la
salatura dell'acqua che mi dicono che
bisognerebbe farlo un altre bolle esatto
e corretto sì sì mi prendo la
responsabilità
sì ma ne sono certo giù giù su cui
continuano a dare l'addio il tempo qua è
veramente 20 minuti ma anche un quarto
d'ora per farlo proprio dall'inizio alla
fine ci vuole niente niente perché per
la rixi cipollini dei passi pomodoro
acque di coduro basilica select aperti
parmigiana che sa di piedi ios caccia
pretendenti io vado a voi la faccio
saltare
no non c'è non c'è volete dite
per prima cosa va aggiunta un po d'acqua
di cottura prima di farla saltare
[Risate]
devo mostrare come si salta perfetto una
battuta orribile ne vergogno ti faccio
vedere però non era facile quella sopra
un piazzamento nord un impiatta mente
facciamo un appartamento nord contro sud
ok per inquietare al nord questo mestolo
più dove vedi massimo tirate girate
girate cosa fare non so che cosa stai
dicendo non idea di che cosa dice
foglioline di un pack e non sa su chi è
che lo voleva il ca trento al sudan
io il piazzamento al sud a una
ricercatezza
ok ecco qui un po di olio a due foglie
di basilico è un po di parmigiano in
trattamento al nord diciamo che ha come
firma la bellezza la ricercatezza delle
geometrie il controllo delle quantità al
sud invece diciamo che il controllo
della porzione c'è si fa in modo di
avere diciamo quello che il fabbisogno
mensile di un piccolo pachiderma c'è
sicuramente una ricercatezza nei colori
che vengono tutti quanti tappati dal
parmigiano sud regna a tavola con la sua
abbondanza è arrivato il momento di
assaggiarli ma se vi è piaciuto questo
video vi invito a fare un salto sul
canale youtube di conad per vedere
quello che abbiamo fatto vi lascio qua
sotto tutti quanti link che vi servono
per non perdere le puntate che abbiamo
fatto insieme a chiara e marcello come
sempre vi invito a iscrivervi a questo
canale e mettermi un bel pollice in su
per il ma soprattutto dell'invito ad
attivare la campanella delle notifiche
per non perdere i video del giovedì è la
cucina buttata della domenica arriviamo
a questo punto al momento dell'assaggio
la sede pronti certe mai assaggiato
questo piatto appuntamento è madonna in
realtà è andata meglio di tutti perché
se quello con la pasta più condita nei
molti vanno giù il buonissima pazzesca
non ci si sbaglia mai un no resta poi da
buttare un altro chilo ma tanto quella
di rim si può toccare perché se non lo
hai capito qual è intangibile
schizzinoso della mia
i ragazzi sono parlando dell'essenza
dell'italia sono amate la pasta al
pomodoro odiate il vostro paese visti
comunque ragazzo ci vediamo giovedì
prossimo
ciao ciao